les élections législatives approchent le
premier tour est au programme le 12 juin
prochain tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir
plus clair sur les enjeux dans chacune
des 12 circonscription des yvelines
dernier focus aujourd'hui avec michael
et demi d'euros bonjour bonjour de la
rédaction de tv 78 avec vous on va
parler justement de la 12e
circonscription déjà où se situe ce
territoire dans les yvelines cette
circonscription est situé au centre des
yvelines et au monde vers le nord du
département elle englobe 23 communes on
retrouve des villes de tailles
importantes comme poissy ou encore
plaisir des communes de taille moyenne
avec bell ou orgeval mais également des
petites communes avec toi hrivik
neauphle-le-château ville il m'a yeux
voici sans avoir encore goupillière un
territoire entre zones urbaines et
ruralité chez les cartes seront
redistribuées dans cette circonscription
puisque la députée sortante florence
granger ne se représente pas
effectivement grigori florence granger
élu sous l'étiquette la république en
marche a décidé de ne pas se représenter
pour un second mandat sur la 12e
circonscription à la selon ses mots
préféré laisser sa place après cinq ans
elle avait remporté ce territoire en
2017 en obtenant 56 63 % des suffrages
face à david douillet du parti
républicain une vraie surprise à
l'époque puisque ce territoire voter
principalement à droite et du coup qui
sont les candidats pour ce scrutin alors
le parti de la majorité présidentielle
ne compte pas abandonner cette
circonscription qui lui semble promis
aux élections présidentielles d'avril
dernier quelques exemples emmanuel
macron avait réalisé
31,28 % à des suffrages à poissy au
premier tour et 75,2 pour son second
orgeval le président sortant avait
réalisé 44 60 % au premier tour et 76 %
au second a plaisir à même dynamique
emmanuel macron est devant en premier et
au second tour pour garder ce territoire
karl olive a été choisi par la majorité
présidentielle maire de poissy depuis
2014 il est très proche du président il
se à présentera sous l'étiquette
ensemble il est également conseiller
départemental des yvelines depuis 2015 à
à 53 ans il se présente pour la première
fois à la députation il aura face à lui
un candidat et l'ère françois moutot il
est élu depuis près de 30 ans à la
mairie touahri cet ingénieur agronome de
formation n'a pas hésité à se porter
candidat sur cette 12e circonscription
il compte sur son implantation locale
pour l'emporter il y aura aussi un
candidat annuler ce avec edwin le gris
un écologiste qui espère surfer sur les
bons résultats de jean luc mélenchon et
des écologistes dans la circonscription
en avril dernier pour l'emporter en ce
mois de juin le candidat multiplient à
ces derniers jours les tractages sur le
terrain l'eau rassemblement national
sera aussi présent sur le secteur avec
jean-louis mais lemaitre lés ce
conseiller en formation était déjà
candidat au premier tour des élections
municipales de mars 2020 à plaisir là le
parti reconquête sera aussi présent dans
cette circonscription avec sabine
clément cette femme de 56 ans mère de
trois enfants et heavy noise depuis 20
ans veut transmettre sa passion
française à tout ça va tenter de percer
sur ce territoire qui n'a pas été très
réceptif aux idées d'eric zemmour lors
de la dernière présidentielle il y aura
quatre autres candidats légalement il y
aura également jean pierre mercier porte
parole de lutte ouvrière il est ouvrier
cariste chez states is à pois s'il était
déjà candidat en 2017 il avait réalisé
un score de 0 60% il ya cinq ans le
parti animalistes sera aussi présent
avec mathieu ap hm paranthoën un
protecteur du bien-être animal il espère
faire 4 % sur la circonscription avec
ses propositions il veut notamment
interdire la chasse à courre sommes
enfin il y a quatre autres candidats qui
se présenteront dimitri carbonnel
candidat écologiste indépendant il y
aura aussi à la mine boudia de l'union
des démocrates musulmans français et
deux autres candidats indépendants jean
marc tran et isabelle fourni hier au
total il y aura onze candidats sur cette
12e circonscription anticipé dit qu'il
restait quatre candidats il reste un peu
plus et au total onze candidats sur
cette 12e circonscription des yvelines
voici toutes les informations à retenir
et à connaître sur cette circonscription
des yvelines merci michael pour ce point
d'information et le tour d'horizon des
circonscriptions est maintenant terminée
retrouver tous les enjeux
circonscription par circonscription et
aussi la liste complète de ces candidats
yvelinois pour les élections
législatives sur notre site internet tv
78 points comme on rappelle les dates de
ce scrutin les 12 et 19 juin prochains